when you look in a mirror what do you
see
well hopefully yourself except it's not
really yourself is it
and i'm not just saying that because
it's a reflection not a living thing
but what i mean is that it's a mirror
version of yourself
and it's non-superimposable the same can
be said about your left and right hands
they're non-superimposable now the
interesting thing
is that these concepts also apply to
chemical compounds
and this includes dna rna and proteins
the building blocks of life dna twists
one way around
not the other it's a right-handed helix
not a left-handed helix
and proteins follow a similar handedness
there are so-called l-amino acids that
make up proteins
not the amino acids with l and
the amino acids being mirror images of
themselves
now the thing is it could have quite
easily been the other way around
we could have ldna and d proteins
as these mirror image systems are
independent from life
as far as we know as in they would still
perform the same function
it would just be a reflected version of
it
and so it wouldn't just be another
branch from the tree of life
it would be a completely new tree so
hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
explore a bit further this concept of
mirror image
biology and discuss some recent work
that's exploiting this knowledge
to be able to store dna as this mirror
image version may be better at storing
dna information
than its natural form but this comes
with its own complications so to begin
with
let's take a look at this mirror image
biology and explore
further these concepts that i've just
been spurting out such as right-handed
and left-handed dna
and l-proteins and d-proteins as this
concept
is that one thing you must remember or
nothing that follows will seem wondrous
so that concept that i'm alluding to is
known as chirality
and it's a property of asymmetry that's
important in several branches of science
and so the definition is that if an
object or a system is chiral
it is distinguishable from its mirror
image that is
it cannot be superimposed onto it and so
you have a chiral object
and its mirror image and together
they're known as enantiomers
and so chirality is a feature of dna and
proteins
well and rna as well and so in the case
of proteins this figure shows it nicely
whereby you've got an amino acid which
is a building block of proteins
and you can see here both of its
enantiomers and how they're mirror
images of each other
you can't actually superimpose them onto
each other
i say one of these virgins is known as l
amino acids
and that makes up all of the proteins
that are found in our natural world
and then the other version this mirror
version is known as the amino acids
and the fact that all amino acids in a
protein have the l version
gives proteins the property of
homochirality
and this term can also apply to dna
whereby each nucleotides
which makes up dna is of the d
nucleotide version
not the l nucleotide version and so this
right versus left-handed
d first as l refers to how chirality was
initially defined
for chemicals whereby if polarized light
is passed through
a chiral molecule the light is either
rotated clockwise or anti-clockwise
so if it's clockwise to the right it's
known as
dextro rotary whereby if it's
anti-clockwise
to the left it's known as level rotary
and so i might interchangeably call them
d
and l or right and left so you've got l
for left
and d for right so hopefully you're now
familiar with the concept of chirality
because i don't want to lead you now
because now we're going to look at what
this mirror world of biology
could really mean well technically we're
first going to look at our world of
biology
and the so-called central dogma that
underpins
well not everything but a kind of
central process
that goes on within ourselves and that
is gene expression
and so the central dogma was termed by
francis crick
which describes the process by which the
information and dna
are converted into a functional product
and
the stages of that are first the
transcription
of dna into rna which is the messenger
that takes it out of the nucleus and the
cytoplasm
where that message is read by the
ribosome and translated into protein
now i've just summarized a whole load of
biochemistry into a very short sentence
so
apologies but all we need to know is
that we've got dna
we've got rna and we've got protein and
how we go between these different stages
depend on rna molecules and they depend
on enzymes
enzymes being proteins and now we can go
back to talking about chirality and how
we have d
dna and we have l proteins and how
this whole process depends on
interactions between proteins
rna and proteins and dna and rna dna
interactions
and so they have kind of co-evolved
together
i mean the origin of these different
molecules is a video on its own
but they've evolved together such that
the system wouldn't work if you then had
d proteins instead of l proteins and so
to summarize that little bit into a
sentence
it would be to say a living system
usually deals with two enantiomers
say the mirror image and the original of
the same compound
in drastically different ways and so the
mirror world of biology
is the hypothesis that if our world
works then the mirror versions of each
of these components
would also work and fulfill the central
dogma however
a mirror image form of life has not yet
been discovered
but the individual components can be
created
so why would we want to further
understand this mirror world of biology
and does it have any potential
therapeutic use or
any other uses that might be interesting
so there are many potential
practical applications of mirror image
biochemistry
for example because as i've mentioned a
living system would usually deal with
the mirror image version
and the normal version in completely
different ways
it has the consequence that our body's
molecular machinery
wouldn't necessarily recognize the
myriad version
of say dna or rna or proteins and so one
that could mean that they're resistant
to enzymatic degradation
and so their half-life within the body
could be longer and it could also
potentially avoid triggering immune
responses
making them attractive drug candidates
and indeed many
mirror image peptides so parts of
proteins have already been
investigated as potential therapies for
different diseases
such as cancer and one peptide was also
made
known as photodri which was shown to
have synalytic activity
and they will revisit this idea later
due to the fact that
especially dna is resistant to enzymatic
degradation
it could have potential as dna storage
but like the structure of dna
there's a twist and the twist is that if
you want to mass generate
this mirrored version of dna you need
enzymes
to synthesize the dna the most efficient
way to do this is to have enzymes that
can synthesize the dna
and then have other enzymes that you can
use to
sequence the dna and check that that you
got it right
and so these enzymes are proteins and so
these proteins have to therefore be the
d proteins not the l proteins because
we're in the mirror world
but to get to the proteins we need to
have the dna that encodes the proteins
that can then go to the intermediate of
rna that can then get translated to
produce the protein
and so where'd you begin and how do you
begin and how do you
begin to even think about the ribosome
which is this huge complex
which mediates the translation of the
rna code into protein
itself made up of different rnas and
proteins
it's a big challenge but i suppose it is
why i found this recent nature
publication
so interesting and decided i had to talk
about it
because when i said it's a big challenge
it is a challenge
however at the moment there are ways
that we can chemically synthesize
short fragments of dna and short
peptides
however it's just not very efficient and
so a couple of labs are looking into
ways of being able to
create the mirrored image version of
different
dna polymerases so create the enzyme
first synthetically
because with one enzyme you can create a
lot of dna
and then you can then have that dna to
then make other proteins or they're
actually not really there yet
but you get the gist but this will make
a lot more sense when we look at
exactly what they did in this nature
publication so
what they wanted to do was to chemically
synthesize the mirror image version
of the 775 amino acids
hyperthermostable high fidelity dna
polymerase
and this is from the species pyrococcus
furiosis
and so the l version of this polymerase
is commonly used in the lab
especially in pcr reactions so it's a
way to amplify dna
and so it's basically a very useful tool
to have in molecular biology
and to be very useful therefore for
developing the mirror image world
but the caveat is that this protein is
775 amino acids long
whereas currently there are limits on
how big you can chemically synthesize
proteins
with anything larger than 400 amino
acids being very challenging to do
so to overcome these problems the
authors had to be quite clever
and so what they did is firstly they
split up the protein into two fragments
in a way that they know won't really
affect his enzymatic activity
and in addition to aid with the chemical
synthesis they made some substitutions
so swapping some amino acids for other
amino acids
that helped to aid in the purification
of the protein during the chemical
synthesis
and so bottom line they were able to
create this 90 kilodalton
high fidelity mirror image dna
polymerase
now the interesting thing about this
paper is what they then did with this
polymerase firstly they showed that with
this mirror image polymerase
they could assemble the dna gene
encoding the 16s
ribosomal rna gene and so this brings us
closer to
approaching potentially the
reconstruction of the ribosome
more interestingly was the fact that
they also used the system to show that
it could work
just as well as the normal system in dna
storage
if not better so just to back up a
little bit
dna data storage is the idea that we can
use the dna sequence
to encode large amounts of digital
information in an enzyme-driven
sustainable and low-cost approach with
the idea that dna
being quite dense and durable could be a
better alternative
to storing a large amount of data in a
small amount of space
and so what needs to be done is having
some way of converting the binary
digital codes
into the four-letter nucleotide code
but that conversion is the easy bit the
bigger challenge is making sure that the
dna is biostable and that that same
information can be recollected
after a passage of time and so what they
did in this paper is actually compare
the ability of dna information storage
in the
normal version of dna with the mirror
image version of dna
so what they did is they took 100 base
pairs of either normal
d or the mirror imaged l version of dna
and this was encoding information about
a sample collection
in this case it was a pond in beijing
and so what they did was they put these
dna fragments into some water from this
pond
and so this water contains all kinds of
and they're weird
bacteria and stuff in it and so they
wanted to see if the
information stored in the mirror image
dna could have faded biodegradation and
contamination from natural environments
and so what they found was that the ldna
barcodes retained the information about
the sample collection for up to one year
and potentially longer than that
whilst the information stored in the
d-dnas to the normal dna version
could not be retained after just one day
in the same conditions
and so the rationale for this is that
the enzymes present
in the pawn sample that degrade dna
recognize the d
version of dna not the mirror image l
version of dna
and so therefore dna storage is a
potential application
of ldna but another interesting
application they show
i think here just a bit for fun is the
idea that
ldna could also be used for
steganography
now this was actually my favorite bit of
the paper and so steganography
is a way of hiding messages in plain
sight
in fact i can demonstrate this because i
actually put a hidden message
in this video whereby earlier on in the
video i said
because i don't want to lead you now
which is actually some lyrics from
justin timberlake's song
mirrors now that's probably not the best
example
actually it probably isn't even an
example of steganography but hopefully
it gives you an idea
of what steganography is and so what
they did here
is exploit the ability to store
information in dna
but have the dna version encoding the
background message
with an inserted fragment of ldna
encoding the hidden message
and so the idea is it's hidden in plain
sight and the reason it's hidden
is because ldna requires different
methods to
sequence the dna sequence because again
the way we sequence dna depends on
enzymes enzymes are protein sense
and those proteins recognize dna or ldna
and so there are two different methods
to sequence the dna
and so if you just use the conventional
approach you would miss the hidden
message
and so if only the dna part was
sequenced it would reveal the false
message
error whilst using the mirror image
method of sequencing it would reveal the
secret message
mirror so this is a genuine example of
steganography
anyway by being able to generate the
mirror image version of this dna
polymerase in this publication
they demonstrate that they've expanded
the mirror image molecular toolbox
for potential applications in
biotechnology and medicine
as i hinted to you earlier a big major
hurdle in this mirror image biology
system is to be able to create
a functional mirror image ribosome and
so i think that's where future work is
being focused on
and this just leaves us with one final
thought
why is life's chirality the way it is
could it be down to chance
or could it have been triggered by a
fundamental asymmetry in nature
and how do we know that it's not there
if we can't necessarily sequence these
strands by normal metagenomic techniques
as in we're not actually looking for
them how do we know that they're not
there
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence so maybe there's a mirror world
under our noses and we just don't know
it anyway i hope you found something in
this video about the mirror image world
of biology
let me know your thoughts down below
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening